- [Voiceover] So I have
this yellow rectangle here,
and I have begun to fill
it with green squares.
And my question to you, and to me,
is how many total green squares
can I fit into this yellow rectangle
if we don't make any of the green squares
sit on top of each other?
Well, let's see.
We already have,
One, two, three, four
green squares.
And let's add a few more.
So I could put one right over here.
So, that's one right over there.
And then I could put
another one right over here.
Put another one right over there.
And so I'm gonna have, one,
two, three, four, five, six
green squares can be
fit into this rectangle.
Now let's look at this big yellow square.
And we have the same thing going on.
We've already started to
fill it with some squares,
and my question to you is,
how many total squares
could we fill this with?
So let's start doing that.
So in this space right over here,
let's put more of these
squares of the same size.
These squares of the same size.
I'm gonna draw 'em first
and then we can count them.
So there you go, and then
one more right over here.
And so you could fit, now
we're ready to count them.
One, two three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine
of these smaller squares
inside of this bigger yellow square.